hey youtubers it's Charlie what would
you say if I told you there was a Batman
version of the flash that was more evil
than savat R I can't do the Morpheus
voice but this is like the best thing
ever you guys may have heard about this
big event that's happening this summer
so there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video they just released a preview of
the big summer event that's happening in
the next couple of months
it's called Dark Knight's metal Batman
is this big Batman Dark multiverse
themed event this sort of a rebirth
level event capping Scott Snyder's work
on the Batman character as far as I know
though this is not connected to what's
going on in rebirth with Geoff Johns in
the Justice League vs The Watchmen
that's going to be culminating in
November with Superman vs dr. Manhattan
in the Justice League movie so if you
never read comics before now is the time
to start but they just released the
first issue it's called dark days they
teased a couple big things that I'll
explain in a second but these crazy
versions of the Justice League are just
too awesome this is going to be great I
can't wait to see dads in comic book
stores explaining murder machine Batman
to their kids so the big preview they
just released is for all the one shots
that are going to be tie-ins you
basically have members of the Justice
League that are all corrupted by Batman
in this dark multiverse you have Batman
the Red Death that's the version of the
flash not to be confused with Red Death
Red Hood which I think was the name of
the story when Jason Todd first debuted
his Red Hood in the comics so in this
dark multiverse the flash is known as
the Red Death the costumes look a little
bit different it's not like god of death
speedster flash but I'm gonna go ahead
and use this picture just because it's
so hardcore this is the closest thing we
have to it so far so far the most evil
versions of the flash we've seen are
actually Johnny quick from Earth 3 whose
crime syndicate flash in sabot are from
the flash TV show so this is like the
most evil version corrupted by Batman
Batman flash the most hardcore of them
all because that's what Scott Steiners
been teasing way beyond emo Barry from
flash season 3 way beyond the more
pessimistic hardcore version of future
flash from the new 52 so let me know in
the
who is your favorite version of hardcore
Barry Allen either the evil Barry's god
of death flash future flash saboteur or
just someone else from the multiverse
displace yourself throughout time exist
every single moment thereof it was all
of us aware and connected through one
consciousness I'll be everywhere every
hour every minute and then I will rule
from the Big Bang until the end of the
world murder machine Batman is just that
dark multiverses version of Bruce Wayne
the merciless is the Batman version of
Wonder Woman the Drowned is the Batman
version of Aquaman the Devastator is the
get this doomsday version of Batman
that's right there's a version of
doomsday that became Batman so that
wasn't enough there's also Batman the
man who laughs that's right a version of
the Joker that became Batman not quite
as new of an idea you probably saw this
at Comic Con last year people actually
thought this was going to be in The
Suicide Squad movie but it's just a Dark
Knight Returns variant of the Joker
costume wearing a Batman costume that
looked very similar to Ben Affleck's
costume really is just based on The Dark
Knight Returns Batman people crapped
themselves when they thought that he was
going to wear this in the movie and I'm
so glad that he did not but the whole
idea behind this dark universe is a
mystery Batman being a detective
uncovers they connects all the nth metal
on the planet to all the special objects
so you have Aquaman's Trident you have
Wonder Woman's bracers it's even in dr.
fates helmet so you have this mysterious
energy signature that's connecting all
the most powerful artifacts on the
planet you learn it's all about this
green substance called Dionysia so it
sounds like the Dionysian is actually
something that connects the dark
multiverse to our multiverse in viewing
all these objects with their special
abilities while this is all going on in
present-day you have Hawkman in the past
trying to learn the secret of his nth
metal where he gets his powers from the
secrets of Resurrection first contact
with nth metal is what triggers Hawkman
and Hawkgirl cycle of death and rebirth
in Batman even connects a tooth that can
bring the dead back to life you see the
court of Alice stuff happening here in
the background so very clearly it's an
nth metal tooth so you have all this DC
Comics Lord that centered around Batman
Hawkman Hawkgirl in the dark multiverse
but because this is all a big preview
for the story that's coming you have to
get to the dark multiverse so obviously
they're teasing a big conflict and this
is a huge deep cut so just careful for
spoilers the Batman goes to Superman it
asks him about the special room that he
had him build that no one could enter so
inside the fortress of solitude Superman
has a special room where he's keeping
something safe for Batman and he's
thrown the key into the Sun the whole
joke with the fortress of solitude is
the key to open it just sits right
outside but it's made of a metal of it's
so dense that only Superman could lift
it or Supergirl just a funny way of
challenging anybody that would seek to
come steal from him but even he can't
get back into the secret room that he
built for Batman something deep dark
that they were never meant to visit
again Batman finds that there's
something alive in the metal of the
Earth's core so in order to investigate
the mystery he has to go into this
mystery room that he was never supposed
to go back into but because they can't
open the door he has to go to the
universe's greatest locksmith scot-free
that's right he goes to one of the new
gods who slips in then comes out and
just automatic hard pass Bale's Batman
don't go in there peace I'm out of here
you guys are screwed and this is where I
almost fell out of my chair you see that
Batman has been keeping hidden alexander
luthor juniors tower that he was using
to combine earth to and earth three from
Infinite Crisis made from the corpse of
the anti-monitor so this is basically
connecting all the way back to Infinite
Crisis it's going back to the beginning
of the DC Universe but like I said all
of this Batman dark universe story is
not connected to what's happening in
Reapers so what it seems like is going
to happen is that Batman will do the
unthinkable and in order to get to the
dark multiverse he will activate this
engine opening a bridge or even full-out
combining the dark multiverses version
of earth with ours so that you'll meet
all these crazy corrupted versions of
Batman you see this crazy statue of
Batman that's basically there earth
you're seeing so you're getting a brief
teaser
for that so let me know what do you guys
think about this I love these hardcore
variants on the Justice League everybody
becomes Batman doomsday becomes Batman
cannot wait to see what their costumes
look like but those are you asking about
the flash Batman Button stuff that's
happening in rebirths I'll do more
videos about that later but that's all
about the lead-up to the Justice League
versus the Watchmen The Watchmen being
the villains of that story Geoff Johns
has explained that that's basically
Superman reminding dr. Manhattan of his
humanity because dr. Manhattan is the
person they're teasing is behind all
this craziness in DC Reaper the one who
keeps vaporizing reverse-flash sort of
the super entity that's messing with
things on a cosmic scale that story is
going to end with the Doomsday Clock
story in November timed with the return
of Superman in the Justice League movie
surprise surprise how those things work
out this Scott Snyder dark universe
stuff I think it's supposed to run seven
issues so this should also end later
this year too but there's never been a
better time to read comics there's new
Rick and Morty there's new spider-man
there's new arrow that I'm going to try
and post so I'll get that out as fast as
possible but congratulations to the
latest giveaway winner werewolf 914
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for brand
new reverse-flash and you can click here
to learn how static might be coming to
the DC TV universe thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight